- Okay, you two ready?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yes, yes!
- All right, let's see the first picture.
(cheering)
(dings)
- Yes!
- Ooh!
- That's Jack Nicolson, baby.
(dings)
Yes!
(cheering)
- Yes.
You might want to get
your hand a little closer.
- Yeah, you might want
to start closer, boo.
- Yeah, she's real quick.
(laughing)
All right, let's bring up the next brow.
- Yes.
- Uh oh.
- Ooh.
- Oh.
Oh!
- Is that, like, Brooke Shields?
(dings)
- Oh.
- Brooke Shields.
(dings)
Oh, oh, dammit, dammit!
(cheering)
- All right, let's see the next.
(groans)
(dings)
Oh, oh!
- Momoa! Jason Momoa.
(dings)
Yes!
(cheering)
- All right, this is
good, this is good, okay.
All right.
- That's Aquaman.
- Next one.
(dings)
- Oh God!
- Yes!
- Thank goodness.
- It's really good you got your son.
- Daniel Levy.
(dings)
- That would have been so awkward.
- That would have been amazing
if I would have gotten it and you didn't.
- Okay, next brow.
(dings)
- Martin Scorsese.
- Woo!
- Oh God, I--
- Ding, ding!
- Awww.
It's a close game.
- I'm gonna lose!
- This will be the first time
I ever lose
- I can smell--
on this show.
- I can smell that pie.
(laughing)
- All right, you ready?
Ready?
(cheering)
- Okay!
- Next round.
(dings)
- Frida!
- Yeah!
- Yes!
(cheering)
- Yes.
- Yes, we tied, we tied!
- who is that?
Frida!
The Mexican artist, Frida.
- Yes, she's a very famous Mexican artist.
- Oh, that Frida.
- She's got the unibrow.
- Okay, let's see the
next picture
- Oh, that Frida!
(dings)
- Oh, um, oh, umm.
She in-- Oh my God, I know
this, I know this, I know this.
- You better know this.
- No, I know I know this,
I know this. Um, um.
(dings)
He can steal.
I know this, I'm blanking.
- Oh, you're gonna really hate yourself.
- Am I?
- Yeah.
- [Woman In Audience] Oh, no!
- Go ahead.
- Am I?
- Meryl Streep?
- Oh.
(buzzer)
- Meryl Streep has blue eyes.
Oh, Gwen!
- Oh!
(cheering)
- That's not who I thought it was.
That's not who I thought it was.
I though it was, like, an actress,
like from the, like long ago, like 40's.
- Well, it's like retro Gwen.
- Yeah, because her
eyebrows, so she's retro
I thought it was somebody
from like-- Sorry, Gwen!
- Ooh.
Wow.
- I know all your music.
That counts, right?
- I think it's still tied.
- Sorry.
- It's still tied.
- Okay.
- Yeah, sorry Blake.
- Let's see the next picture.
- Okay.
(dings)
Oh God, he got it!
(laughs)
- M-I-C.
- No.
(buzzer)
(laughing)
That's--
(dings)
That's Mario!
(cheering)
- What?
- K--
K-E-Y.
- Can we give him a
half point for singing?
- You can give him a point for singing,
we're tied.
- Well, show me--
We're tied, he sang.
- When did Mickey Mouse get blue eyes?
- Dude, I'm a Mario Brothers freak.
- Let's see the next brow.
(dings)
Oh.
- Groucho.
- Ahh!
(dings)
(cheering)
- The right side is getting excited.
Okay.
- That's it?
- Wait, that's it!
- Ahhhh! The winner is Eugene!
(dings)
(cheering)
- Thank you, thank you.
- Congratulations.
- Yes!
Congratulations.
- Thank you, Kelly.
I mean, the song alone got you the win.
- And blame me.
- It was, it was--
- I know this hurts,
- It does, I hate losing!
- 'cause you're as
competitive as my son, Dan.
- Yes!